foreign
interest rates as you plan unemployment
will be 4.6 percent by the end of the
year and that would be about 2 million
people if you could speak directly to
the 2 million who you're planning to get
fired over the next year what would you
say to them inflation is extremely high
and it's hurting the working people of
this country badly all of them not just
2 million of them and we are taking the
the only measures we have to bring
inflation down and
putting two million people out of work
is just part of the cost and they just
have to have to bear it well they will
will working people be better off if if
we just walk away from our jobs and and
inflation remains five six percent
there's been 12 times that we've seen a
one point increase in the unemployed in
the unemployment rate in a year how many
times did the economy fail to fall into
a recession after doing that out of 12th
time I think the number is zero I think
the number is zero that's exactly right
ouch Elizabeth Warren bring in the Heat
and this is where I'm shocked but I
actually agree with her uh this is a
situation where Jerome Powell folks has
gone on record many times you can get on
the Google if you think I'm making this
up and he has said it is an unfortunate
pain point that we're gonna have to get
to to see unemployment go up and his
idea is if unemployment goes up because
we are raising the cost of borrowing
raising the cost of doing business that
companies will lay people off now we've
seen big Tech do that and he's flirting
with a recession because he's hoping
that people will companies will lay
people off what happens then is is the
job demand goes down in his mind
and so now people aren't having to pay
as much because he knows that wage
pressures Rachel are causing right
inflation to be stubborn here's the
challenge with what he said
it's not the only tool he has
the FED screwed this up the FED flushed
too much money into the economy and got
us to this point because they were
worried about the pandemic this is what
happens when the federal government and
the Federal Bank gets involved in the
economy he then says ironically what you
would you have us do Senator Warren walk
away from our jobs Yes actually I would
like you feckless fed share pal to walk
away and just let the economy figure out
do its thing here's why
yes inflation has made a household
budget much higher however
to force two million people or maybe
more because here's the deal these are
projections we're at 3.4 percent
unemployment right now historicals if it
gets pushed and there are quotes where
he said Rachel it may get to six percent
unemployment and that may be what it
takes so you're going to drive millions
of people
to unemployment
and you think that's going to fix it but
here's the issue we've got five to six
million jobs available
I know I'm paying it off we've got five
to six million jobs available right now
in this economy so if you drive an
unemployment they're gonna go get
another job and we're not going to fix
it and oh by the way let's step back
Rachel has the interest rate increase
done anything to unemployment so far no
it has not he's been steadily raising
the rates and unemployment is still it's
still low because there's so many jobs
so why does this matter to you folks who
come to a money show because we have
debt free streamers every day on this
show every week every month and
inflation isn't affecting them because
they're not looking to DC in the fed and
interest rates they're taking control of
their money so these headlines and while
it is painful you can control your money
no matter how expensive groceries are
you can actually control your future
through your spending and your saving in
Ramsay Solutions and the Ramsey show is
here to help you do it we don't care
what Jerome Powell does at the end of
the day because he doesn't have a
freaking clue and we are in control of
our money we got you don't worry about
the headlines this is the Ramsey Show